hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am
Danielle Danielle is here Danielle new
to the channel extremely nervous to be
on camera right now she is examining
every one of her movements she is
nervous she's one of the most energetic
wacky people I've ever known and now she
is shutting down completely shutting
down shutting down a lot of people are
asking us to check out this video called
Robert Downey jr. walks out of an
interview when asked questions about his
past this is apparently brand new
happened during an interview for age of
Ultron
I like it when celebrities get mad it's
really entertaining when celebrities get
mad it is who's the last Liberty
remember you're now Jepsen no that was
years ago
Alec Baldwin Alec Baldwin when he chewed
out his daughter Kanye when he hit up
hit the paparazzi guy oh yeah I know
that of all that I think Alec Baldwin's
daughter deserved it the most for sure
between Mel Gibson Alec Baldwin and
Kanye the daughter was the one who
really had it coming I agree you say
with merging an interview I mean
promoting the movie I mean obviously
you're doing a promotional round of
interviews and that's why we're talking
about the movie but we also relax it'll
be a year other now how comfortable you
are you know talking talking a man
yourself for the moment you have as much
time as anyone else well yeah well okay
well then let me just ask you a few more
questions and you can answer them if you
want to not if you don't want to I mean
um well I think we've got two three more
minutes on are not another group your
face starting to jump a little bit you
better get to your next question sex
line you um the reason I'm asking about
the past is that you
you've talked in other interviews again
about your relationship with your father
and the role of all of that in the dark
periods you entered and taking drugs and
drinking all of that big whisper is it I
just wanted to whether you know you
think you're free of any thoughts or
whether that's still some sorry I really
don't know what are we doing
ah well I'm just asking questions that's
wrong
but are you sad
Oh Oh Waco there's got to be a longer
version of that sure hold on a second I
swear there's a longer version I feel
like he's right so in the past
it's so like been there done that yeah I
want to get to where he gets mad Oh area
like I was Tony Stark but I felt like it
was my persona but none of us are our
personas but he's becoming a much more
likable character as well isn't he
I suppose that's a man yeah it's
becoming a better guy you know in a way
that you all are as well as dono good
man I'm talking about a quote you get
the New York Times and I always cry so
you don't agree that's fine but what you
said to the New York Times once was it
was about I was after your incarceration
and you said you can't go from a two
thousand dollar a night hotel suite to
the penitentiary and understand it I'm
cut out of liberal and I just wonder
what you meant by that
right well the funny thing is and I
appreciate your your point of view these
that you said five seven years ago where
things you said in an interview that
made sense to you at the time I could
pick that I can pick that apart for two
hours and no because we know closer to
the truth than I'd be giving you some
half-assed answer right now I couldn't
even really tell you what a liberal is
so therein lies the answer to your
question the stainless sort of stands by
itself doesn't it does that mean you're
not all that you came out prison not
being are we promoting a movie to me the
thing is that it's I'm certainly not
going to backpedal on anything I've said
but I would I want to say actually I
wouldn't say I'm a Republican or liberal
or a Democrat I think when I was talking
to the person who was doing the
interview that day and and that just
happened to be my opinion
that's the nice thing is you can have
opinions and they kind of change from
the flow
yeah well does That's Life that's gross
but yeah I mean you say we promoting it
into your I'm promoting a movie I mean
obviously getting a promotional round of
interviews and that's what I'm talking
about
we also would like to talk a little bit
about you I don't know how comfortable
you are talking about yourself at the
moment you have as much time as anyone
else well yeah well okay well then let
me just ask you a few more questions and
you can answer them if you want to or
not if you don't want to um well I think
we've got two three more minutes on its
skin like progressively annoyed you know
a little bit you better get to your next
question his eyes are getting red
oh my god he's turning evil um the
reason I'm asking about the past is that
you nice one you've talked seen other
interviews again about the relationship
with your father the role of all of that
in you look so mad as green taking drugs
and drinking and all of that and I just
want to feel like he's good at him you
know you think you're free of all of
that or whether that's still some sorry
I really don't know what are we doing ah
well I'm just asking questions that's
run by you I'm sorry okay do you see
you're kind of a schmuck I think he said
you're kind of a dinosaur well don't
which would be crazy wouldn't make any
sense Danielle but I really swear I
heard him say that yeah let's all play
it back
the simple surface thank you
look I don't want to get back yeah he's
getting a little dinosaur II buddy then
he called him a schmuck
what is I'm a meal because Scorpius like
you say I am soaring science ordering
that's what he was saying we both look
like idiots they're dinosaur I was so on
board when he said that Jim and you were
gonna come oh yeah like oh it makes
sense this is news from the past
this is extinction okay you were gonna
say to me came up with a whole spiel
first off love seeing him get mad that
is just entertaining I'm never gonna
forget that he's like the perfect it is
kind of an attractive kind of anger he's
like so just swab that's a lot of
intensity in his eyes he's not just like
and he knows what to say and buy your
bag yeah that way I love that about him
you know I am so over like his past for
sure so long ago I know it's dinosaur
yes his mortgage it really isn't because
please I'm sure I get so annoying to be
in interviews and like here are the same
questions that you've answered
do you feel like he responded the right
way though like do you think he could
have like handle that a little better
- the last question a whole interview -
the last questions about like his past
well yeah he probably could just then
like I'm good yeah I don't think he had
to get soon had yeah I didn't have to
like walk out yeah it was a little diva
like but at the same time it's Robert
Downey jr. so I'm like you did the right
thing Robert I believe in whatever you
do even when I doubt you I never got him
I love his body me town he is Iron Man
with or without that suit is that what
you call like your boyfriend Michael
it's time - oh can you get that cuz he
gets really big when it's time to
Captain America cuz he has flying discs
yes fine
got a lion discs what's the source of
your reference - exactly yeah yeah I do
that was amazing at the end of the day
it is total [ __ ] like this guy had
to work his ass off to get back into the
business and really succeed you know for
the first time first Ironman he only
made $500,000 which is like so low for
these comic book movies really yeah cuz
that's how little of faith they had in
him and how much of a gamble they were
taking but he worked his ass off to get
there and now he's got like I was like
the richest guy in the world ever yeah
and he plays the richest guy in the
world too it's like there are some
things I get where you just want to
leave it in the past because like
actually now looking back today I could
see why I got offended because it seemed
that the guy was judging him yeah you
know and I if you hate it when someone
that's like if I made past mistakes I
know about that but I've overcome them
all right II apologize exactly and then
you still get judged for it that's what
it's like oh my god again it's really
frustrating so we feel you Robert
kill you Robert you can come over you
can come over yeah I'll touch my nipples
balls that's why I brought her that's
why I brought her compliments the jokes
well anyway guys thanks for telling us
that video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects daniel has a life they say
Daniel you did danielle has a like
happiness how annoying is it when people
call you Daniel I don't that doesn't
really happen right danielle has a life
that is not related to the Internet
I can't tell you where to follow her and
you can follow me on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter
I'm sure she has one of those I don't
really keep up with her life ever I know
I I just I talked to her to get close to
her boyfriend so man Captain America
Captain Merridew over there it don't
like The Incredible Hulk you know what I
mean yeah he has discs yeah I just sends
chest is like iron
he's all of The Supremes the other
avenger men were missing I know I was
trying to think of it don't work that's
right door nor he had that yeah he [ __ ]
he's the god of sex thunder for sure yes
yeah yes is he now
yes and he always carries around
just cuz pees into that like a real
hammer not like a Thor hammer like what
like a flick